this lovely episode with josh
potter and the fighter and the kids
is a fun one y'all and guess what this
saturday
this squad is in boise boise idaho 20
tickets left one night one show only in
the theater right outside boise
december 5th this saturday it's gonna be
cold let's snuggle up
let's share some cocoa and have some
laughs and then bring in
the new year 2021 because we can forget
about 2020 for god's sakes
west palm beach improv december 31st
through january 2nd
me and the team will be there bringing
the new year the right way with us but
boise will see you this saturday
take us at tfatkay.com for all that
sick boys fake girls uh new merch just
dropped tie-dye
short sleeve hoodies women's leggings
women's shorts we got it all think
boy.com the melon and berry dye
the thick girl gear thick boy hats you
see me rocking all the time get at
thickboy.com right now
this episode with josh potter is brought
to you by the best supplements on the
goddamn earth i keep telling you guys
about it
join the movement right now go to
onit.com
10 off anything alpha brain uh digestive
uh health total gut health earth grown
nutrients we got protein powder
we got keto stuff creatine we got
workout gear we got
fitness streaming fitness you can do it
from your living room there's no reason
to be thick anymore
you get kettle bells we got sand bags we
got steel maces we got
yoga mats we got jiu jitsu gear we got
it all t-shirts for men women
kids everything you need on it.com
performancewiseonit.com
fighter 10 off the goddamn site on
it.com
fighter i've seen pictures of her what
does she will you pull her up chad
larissa larissa you're an ap you're an
ap science right now dog yeah
he's not ready for that you're not right
get ready for it you he cheated his
whole way nothing i didn't see my whole
way here
we gotta fill chappelle in yeah i gotta
know who this person is
have you seen scottie pippen's old lady
before no
she's she where there you go she goes to
the same doctor as the kardashians so
they all look very similar oh my gosh
she is a she's they're all she's or they
were
friends and she was born yeah so that's
what she's walking around with malik
busily so look that's the guy he
who was married and went out with he's
married yes they're at the mall oh my
god
oh he's like i got a mascot i'm good but
he's six nine like you said
sir you're seven foot yeah but two weeks
ago he tweeted her
he was like yo listen i would love to
take you out on a date and treat you
like a queen why you had a whole wife at
home and you know
yes and here's what's crazy is um
so she larissa pippen was friends with
kardashians
yeah then they kicked her out of the
kardashian clan because
she said that she dated tristan thompson
before chloe
was she ex-communicator now oh she's out
damn
they don't [ __ ] with eskimos
wow wait let's introduce our guests
good to see you brother love the buffalo
bills hat from buffalo yeah i love the
bills all the way baby we're
this is the it's covered here but we're
taking it i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah it's co like there's a little bit
of an asterisk like with the lakers
championships
yeah yeah you guys did it but also it
was pick-up basketball oh hold on hold
on
we did it yeah i'm a big lebron james
shout out baby we did two years
two more years eighty-five million
dollars you know tires of lakers um
um but the the bills first place right
right now yeah yeah in the afc east in
the exes
not uh we're eight and three nine and
three now and uh
yeah i i don't i think we're you know
the steelers obviously are undefeated so
we'll find out today wednesday night
football or whatever if they'll win but
um
yeah the bills are in first place in the
afc's for the first time since i was
like seven because
because uh i'm trying to yeah for reals
they're finally good but josh allen kind
of the real deal i'm a fan of him
big fan and then who else you got you
have the dolphins stefan
diggs came on board best receiver in the
league right now hands down what
tyreke hill he said i hold my beer i he
did do that
after the fact you're right but he was
leading up until that game also homeboy
for minnesota the white boy for
minnesota
yeah he's a beast has he got a lot of
yards uh just touches he's got kirk
cousins is like i don't know what
they're doing with that no i don't know
what what about
from [ __ ] yeah yeah he had a big game
the other night yeah he's a freaking
beast d.k metcalf yeah he's a [ __ ]
physical monster so you're born and
raised in buffalo yeah big
i just moved here to la three years ago
oh [ __ ] so for those who don't know
uh josh's story correct me if i'm wrong
you're you're a comic right and tom came
was it he layman buffalo
yeah and so obviously tom's a headliner
does heal him great club by the way one
of my favorite clubs yeah back in 2013
this was
tom comes there he need you you did a
spot right
yeah i was just um like i was passed by
helium as like a middle it was actually
my first like middle weekend
for helium so it opens for tom so i was
just and tom was like um
i didn't know who he was to be quite
honest with you like it was a time
before netflix specials and all that
it was before tom was really big yeah
yeah so it was um
you know there was still like you know
maybe paper in it a little bit you know
what i mean like so
i didn't know you know you have a
weekend with a guy and you you hit it
off but
i've hit it off bigger with people do
you know what i'm saying yeah where you
go
you're like let's get launched let's get
this like we didn't hang out we just
kind of like we're pleasant
yeah and then like lo and behold he dm's
in me like a couple days later and he's
like do you want to come to orlando and
open for me and then it's just like the
ball started so he must have done well
yeah i guess i just did well yeah he
must have him well because that and then
tom actually go to orlando with him and
then he was basically like
hey just for with 2017 just be my opener
yeah he's like if you move to la you can
have the whole tour
so i was like what am i gonna say no to
that [ __ ] what are you staying up
buffalo
yeah exactly dude there was there was a
guy and we'll go back to your state but
there's a guy
the last time i did buffalo he was rick
matthews he's a good buddy of mine
what's his name he open for you rick
matthews
monster yeah he's great monster he's a
guy he's like correctional he's the only
yeah he's the only guy that i like
started with that sticks around dude
that's like stuck around
still dude i'm saying [ __ ] and i was
just headlining
and buffalo my first places that booked
me as a headliner
and he did 20 um he set that [ __ ]
place on fire
and then me and him hit it off i haven't
talked to him since
there's he was
great he was so cool he reminds my uncle
charlie he was so [ __ ] friendly so
funny
but he uh he's uh he works at a prison
yeah he's like
he he was like he's his neck was real
stiff and
i thought he was doing a bit but he's
like dude like we were we were
on the [ __ ] yard or whatever in the
prison and there was a bat
and he's like you know i was trying to
hit this bat and i fell and hit my head
so he had like a huge lump on his head
and i thought he was doing a bit and i
thought he meant like a baseball bat
he's like nah [ __ ] like a bat
i thought he might have basically that's
what i thought yeah [ __ ] he was such a
good dude though yeah he's great he's
one of my good buddies from
back home in the comedy scene he's so
funny yeah hell yeah and then he
uh told us like all the places to get uh
buffalo
wings you know he was like this is the
original place but that's not the best
the anchor bars
blows stuffs is better stuff gabriel's
gates is better
yes yeah yeah yeah i got the whole run
down you ever
what's up by the way sean from helium oh
don't let me say what's up yeah hell
yeah
what's up he's gonna hear this but uh
yeah is that always weird like make sure
you heard anybody heard this but um
yeah i remember in buffalo when i was
there because i i uh
took a plane i did syracuse on a
wednesday and then took a train
down or up is it up no turkey should be
down down to buffalo
okay yes i went down to buffalo but
there's a blizzard oh and so i'm texting
my agent because it's one of my first
headline kids i'm like dude there's a
blizzard i think i should just fly home
nobody's going to come this is a
nightmare and he's like dude you're in
buffy yeah yeah yeah damn and that
that's when we talked to the man to the
club he's like oh
no dude they don't worry people came on
[ __ ] snowmobile
that [ __ ] was packed yeah dude
and buffalo is dope yeah for you know
offset
i did a short stint with the buffalo
bills out of cappuccino with buffalo
bills and they're like we're all set on
slow white guys
how long did you spend there when you
were there for camping like three weeks
and you just lived out in orchard park
or something yeah
brother i guess i'll pound on that but
you didn't get to like experience the
the city and [ __ ] nah no not really yeah
yeah and then i always had like you know
because they were like no you're not
good enough get out of here so i was
like man [ __ ] buffalo
right and then when i went i was like i
guess i'll do buffalo so i had like this
weird feeling about going there
and then me it was just me and my
brother on the road and we went to
just everyone was so cool like your boy
opened up for me
he was great the manager was cool like
it was such a good time man yeah it's a
great club and it's
i really like the city too i mean i i
liked living i was doing radio there i
was living there
that's your background right yeah yeah i
started in radio how did that come about
i just i wanted to do comedy but i
didn't know like stand-up was a thing
and i was just doing bits and [ __ ] like
on the radio
you know kind of like podcast or
whatever i guess but um
there was no podcast it was i was 16 and
i got a got into radio
it was really weird like i got hired by
a morning show when i was in high school
to do stunts and [ __ ] like jackass [ __ ]
you know get it
yeah so like i was i like i got like my
first thing on the air i got like shot
with the taser and like
jesus yeah stuff like that like when i
was like what a taser yeah like like on
purpose like by a police officer yeah
and you you like willingly said yeah
i've signed whatever it takes
yeah i just did that to get on the air
yeah because they weren't going to do
that what do you say whatever it's like
whatever yeah
i mean yeah yeah yeah so you start in
radio
tom comes along takes you under his wing
you move out to l.a yep
and i'll see tom that was you know about
15 years pass between these two things
between 2003 and 2000 i started comedy
in like 0.809 like when i was
22 yeah so then you move out to la
and then obviously tom's career explodes
right
nicest funniest guys in the game so he
deserves it all but the thing about
tom i assume people know this is
obviously tom's super
funny but there's a few guys in this
game who are funny and also have a
business mind
like tom's quietly i mean you can say
what you want creating a
basically a network you know like he's
quietly building his own network
has great merch has you know he has all
these you know
kind of runoff shows as well as car
shows your mom's house
uh he does you know all those other
shows now you have your own podcast
yeah i'm i'm really thankful that he let
me do a show on there you know what i
mean because it's not like
it's not like he's letting anyone come
in there and do you know what i'm saying
so i mean between like you said he's got
the merch
the way he's conducted his podcast in
the last decade
it's insane to watch something like that
grow and i'm only hoping to learn like
even like a fraction of it you know what
i'm saying like just so i can
like i'm taking what i learned from
radio or whatever and
using it to do a podcast but i'm hoping
like
that some of that [ __ ] rubs off on me
too you know because i'm a better user
you know
yeah yeah i got still learning yeah no
tom setting the game plan man yeah
the monster so you've been here what
three years now three years uh this past
september how long
i thought you were a lot longer no i
moved here and um
did the no teeth no entry tour with him
and there was no promises beyond that it
was the end of
it ended like new year's day 2019 came
or 2018 excuse me
and it was like all right we'll see you
see you around kind of thing you know
and i was like all right and then i got
a job like downtown in an
office and [ __ ] and kept doing shows and
stuff you know trying to get my
name out there around here and um
then he started the studio and he was
like i need some help like getting this
underway
would you work there and i was like [ __ ]
yeah i want to work in this [ __ ]
office
yeah so i just you know i i would show
up there and just like accept packages
like the first couple days it was open
you know like unlock the door for the
people building the [ __ ] and all that
kind of crap and help out in the dave
however he needs help the guy who runs
the place and uh
yeah i mean now now i got a show on and
you couldn't work for a nicer guy
no i would do i would [ __ ] die for
that dude sincerely like i would take a
[ __ ] bullet right now yeah
i would i would take a knife all the way
not a bullet i'd take a knife
knife seems more painful bullet might be
sick i just don't want to die
but uh maybe i don't even know i would
die i would i would sincerely die for
both of them for both tom and christina
yeah i love so much they've been so uh
just so supportive of me you know tom
tom is the type of guy just so you guys
know
i feel like like there's some mystery to
tom but tom's the type of dude where
like obviously i was going through all
my stuff with all the drama with cal and
i didn't know what to do the show
and tom would call and give me advice
yeah i would
i wasn't asked i didn't ask him i texted
him nothing just called like hey can i
give you some unsolicited advice i'm
like i'd love to hear it man
and then he drops just [ __ ] gems on
you yeah you're like oh that makes sense
because he doesn't do that [ __ ]
at all very often no so when he does it
means a lot
it's big yeah it's huge and the me and
thomas you have our
love of uh cars yeah i wish i shared
that with
you fellas i don't drive anymore so well
because of my eyes oh yeah yeah and what
exactly is up with your eyes
i have a macular degeneration and i'm
blinding my right eye all together i
feel like i'm giving
malik the cold shoulder here but i can't
even see you
over here on this side so like what are
you talking about oh [ __ ] are you you
were born with that
no i well i was born with the disease
but um
you know over time i became so
nearsighted from it
and my retinas would tear or whatever so
i've had retinal tears in both
eyes and i've had multiple surgeries in
both eyes and in 2006 i lost this guy
so because it was just like too many and
there's nothing you can do
there's no i mean i've got the eye in my
face still so like
say they come up with some stem cell
[ __ ] or whatever and they can like
make new tissue for your retina or
whatever i can [ __ ] with that but like
otherwise right now i'm just kind of
chilling with it yeah i'm sorry
don't be sorry you've had to do this you
know right
do you have an iphone i do i've used my
iphone to find my glasses because you
could hold the iphone up to your face
yeah like you you have glasses so like
do you see 20 20 or they just for
reading or they feel like chill like no
i had uh
lasik and then my vision started to get
like like lights and like things were
getting like oh you got the like uh yeah
stigmatism or whatever
yeah well for me i'm nearsighted so like
if i take my glasses off i can't see
like you know here
yeah so if i lose my glasses like in my
bathroom or something
yeah i put my iphone like up to my
[ __ ] eye and then i can zoom and [ __ ]
oh that's cool
what's that i need to see what do you
mean cause then i could see like i put
it close enough where i could see
the iphone and then i could zoom with
the iphone and see far away
all right it bothers me yet to describe
that to him
that's my issue today i know i'm all
excited i'm like let him finish
that's my issue i want him to put
iphone's cameras in my face
josh have you now now that like uh your
mom's house is obviously one of the
biggest podcasts in the world
tom's one biggest comics in the world
you're obviously in that
family yeah your dm's just blowing up
they've been wonderful
i'm not gonna lie because well i
remember yeah yeah
i went on your mind because i was
getting a lot of it was like make sure
you ask him about dating and i was like
really she's like yes
no that because i was getting a lot of
dms
and it was awesome uh and so we were
having you on and like
we thought it'd be funny or like let's
see what shaw says about your dm game or
whatever
because i didn't know what to do
i was going to help them out i was like
writing like fantastic things
yeah like you'd be like tits like those
are fun yeah
yeah i'm single but it ends up being uh
not a
you know they don't care what you're
writing those things i feel like no
it's just a jump off yeah you can just
have a little
two eyes in that wave sign i'm like hey
john well that's what i learned it's
less is more i guess yeah that's right
yeah yeah so
are you enjoying the single life or do
you want to kind of i was
um when i was on the road i haven't i
haven't been
uh as blessed as you you've gone on the
road quite a bit i've gotten some stints
here and there
yeah but i i just [ __ ] miss comedy so
much man like it's taken all of my
social life away technically
like agree in l.a yeah man uh clubs and
bars and stuff like that so
um i'm taking like an inventory of
myself right now you know without comedy
because i don't have comedy to distract
me
from like my life i guess you know so
i'm sitting here going like what do i
want
yeah do i want to get married i don't
know yeah it's interesting right it's
like without stand up
i don't think you realize how much it
means to you when it was taken away
right so a lot of people like i can't
believe we're doing standard code but
i'm like
it's actually pretty safe and i'm
actually no it's totally safe it's
totally safe and i'm also giving it back
to the community and
i'm providing a lot of jobs and those
people that need money and
you know i do some stuff behind the
scenes that help out the club so it's
like
you're actually providing a lot to those
places but also just me personally it's
like
i was depressed man like i have my kids
who i
really rely on my family and this
podcast which is my life
and my other podcast but it's like stand
up man like that's my
[ __ ] dude without it i mean i'm sure all
of you you're constantly
working at this this goal that you're
really never gonna finish like a
painting you're never gonna finish
never and you're always working it's
just like being on the road like how
much fun do we have on the road oh it's
a great [ __ ] time
tons for fun it's like when people go
don't you have a vacation or something
like that like
nah well when i do stand up not only is
it the best job in the world but it's
also like
that's my getaway man with my boys
that's the vacation
yeah i straight up like it's up such a
piece of me that
i when i lost it i mean i was going to
do shitty mics all the time like every
day i didn't
like and i didn't realize how much of my
life it consumed
and until it was gone and then i was
like oh i don't have
anything else yeah you know what i mean
like i have poc like you said podcast i
have
you know my friends or whatever but i
like do i want to get a house and [ __ ]
someday like you know what i mean i
started thinking about those things
before you
start thinking about other [ __ ] yeah
like things that you neglected which i
think is good right it is good
because now when comedy comes back i can
apply i go like hey man by the way keep
keep in mind about your life too yes you
know not
just this goal of you know headlining
and [ __ ] like that or whatever you know
so
that's a solid find yeah it is a good
find i hope i mean i'm trying to spin it
to a good place because you know it's
been just a shitty [ __ ] quarantine
where i live in east hollywood oh okay
yeah
yeah and has but and then tom was just
starting to go back on the road
and then obviously he got injured he was
gonna get into that i was waiting
to do that i was going on i had a whole
run
for myself actually this year that yeah
i saw that yeah i was doing a lot of
work i was getting a lot of work
headlining work for the first time 2020
was my first year where i was like
straight up headlining like it wasn't
just like a paper
whatever one off and um
you know i was pumped i was like this is
it this is my [ __ ]
shot you know this i remember being at
uh the comedy store with like brian
simpson and going like
shout out to brian shut up brian simpson
i remember going like on new year's i go
this is our year dude
i remember like cheers me and david
lucas too
i think was there i was like this is it
dude 2020 baby let's go
let's ride baby
and when it came i go a [ __ ] course
and then i was like sitting there today
i'm reading about the vaccine and [ __ ]
and they're like you know
it's effective whatever but it's gonna
take until next fall
for it to be like the economy's back to
normal and i'm like [ __ ]
i can't go another year like this dude
you cannot do it yeah i don't think
you're gonna have to like
uh [ __ ] ass cities you know like
seattle where boeing's at and some other
companies
they they said they're coming back i
think march first
[Music]
well that's like my agent's like hey man
so you know i supposed to do europe and
australia in
2020 obviously that [ __ ] got blown out
he's like let's reschedule for 2021 i
was like [ __ ] you know how lit america
is going to be once this
vaccine drops yeah i ain't going nowhere
man i want one of the best spots in
america i mean i i
hope that's true like i i believe that
to be true too
and i want it to be so insane i want
like
yes i want ticket sales to be inflated
because of it like even the hackiest of
hacks like let them sell out i don't
care
like people are so excited just go out i
don't give a [ __ ] let's let this info i
want to look like a woohang
uh [ __ ] party i want them
you see that yeah that's what i want i
want all my shows look like wuhan
[ __ ]
nothing but asians and water you don't
have to see seed on the floor
yeah let's go everybody in there let's
take a little break from this chat with
our friend josh potter because listen
insurance can be complicated and that's
why the zebra
was created when you use the zebra.com
insurance finally feels like it's black
and white
no more confusion just honest rates from
real
companies the zebra is the nation's
leading insurance comparison site
for car and home insurance they can help
you save money today it's so
damn easy go to the zebra.com answer a
few quick questions
to compare accurate insurance quotes for
free
the zebra protects your personal
information so you get a bunch of spam
stuff and hidden fees none of that all
right
um how much money can you save on home
and
car insurance well visit thezebra.com
fighter that's t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a-dot-com
fighter for insurance in black and white
one unexpected side effect this year it
feels like fashion is over
your world's in black and white it's
gray you're sad
well guess what guess what man fairty
makes high quality comfortable clothing
clothing for life they're sustainably
minded designing products
with a thoughtful focus on fabric we're
talking soft
comfortable right every piece is made to
last forever and it's guaranteed
parity is committed community and
environment and all that they do
the company is run by ferdi family they
are very hands-on
ensuring everything they do lives up to
their values all right
they got this new legend collection
which is pretty legendary it's the
softest coziest shirt i've ever worn
that's ever touched this thick ass body
it's a good thing that the quality
stands up to everyday wear because i
want to wear it every damn day
so get yourself your own legendary shirt
get your own soft shirts all right
and right now is the time to do it you
can get 25
off your next verity purchase when you
go to faradaybrand.com
fighter that's faridy f a h e r
t y brand.com fighter for 25
off veritybrand.com fighter
i think it's also forced comics to get
creative so you're seeing like
kevin hart release specials from his
house and like people are trying to
figure out content
i think i like posted a podcast on
youtube from uh
he did it really great yeah he's a
monster yeah he just released a special
sam morrell
yeah uh on a rooftop in new york and
there's like 30 people
and that's his second special this year
i think it's a completely
quarantined special yeah it's kind of
wild to even
i don't even know i haven't i'm not
gonna lie to you folks i haven't written
a new joke
this year because it's interesting i
just i was trying to hone in my hour and
then like
you know you go out on the road the few
times you get to and you're doing an
hour
cold out of no open mics no anything you
can't even do 10 minutes
somewhere and you go do a cold ass hour
and i'm just trying to remember my old
[ __ ] i know
yeah so i feel like such a [ __ ] loser
right now but you shouldn't because it's
also like but there's also like as far
as writing new jokes right now like
obviously you can have some quarantined
stuff
some covet [ __ ] there's no life to draw
there's no
there's also like there's no right now
there's like i guess there's a little
bit of light at the tunnel
end of the tunnel because the vaccine's
dropping but there's also like
it's hard to get motivated right now to
write about funny [ __ ] right now because
nothing's funny right nothing's
happening
i mean i don't have anything happening
to me my day is just groundhog's day i
wake up
i just try to watch something to pass
the time i don't even know what i'm
doing i go for walks
like there's nowhere to go or are you
are you on dating apps
no actually i'm not because the dms were
so
prominent that i was like i need to see
these why bother
yeah like and also i'm fishing
with uh like a uh
bottomless net on the dating apps
because it's like
they i'm coming at it with no context at
least the people that are hitting me up
in dm's know they know comedian they
know i'm on a show
they know like they know a little they
they think they know a lot about you i
don't know if you find that at all
oh yeah like with girls where they think
like i know you from because i hear you
talk for hours
but like they do know you better than
someone who just sees your picture on a
[ __ ] 100 dating app
yeah you know what i mean so they're
more into you at least than
i would find i don't have good luck out
of context that makes sense
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah i dig
that have you have you found it
challenging
uh or maybe easier since you have your
own show now
it's a different animal right um you
mean as far as
uh the dms go no just as far as like
just hearing the show now you're the
oh yeah carrying the show i mean i've
always it's
it's weird because i've always been a
part of someone else's show since even
in radio
like i was always a part of another
morning show as like a piece of it
everything this is the first time
that i have my own show and i'm doing it
like solo with
we're having guests once a month like uh
every four episodes will be a guest
and um it's just like i'm trying to find
my way you know trying to figure it
out and uh you know i'm it's
something that i was like terrified
about carrying my own like trying to
just fill an hour
of but then you go like i used to do
this for four hours i used to do this
for five hours i could do this for
an hour you know what i mean sure there
was commercials or whatever but
you know you find your way and it's
weird though like doing radio you do
four hours a day
five days a week so like three out three
weeks
in you're like you're in the [ __ ]
groove you know you're in the pocket for
sure
rocking it out this has been tougher
because it's once a week
you tape for an hour and then
it's done and then you come back a week
later and you're like i gotta do it you
know what i mean it's just tough to get
into a
into a group i wish i could do it like
every day yeah technically and
who whose idea was it for you to have
your own show did tom go hey mate you
should do it we were talking about what
did you do
no i mean um tom was like obviously the
logical step is for you to have
a show and then there was like
tom was wondering how like he's like if
this pandemic lasts long enough maybe we
do a show
you know he was already doing two bears
and then your mom's house and i was like
you want to do another show and he was
like if i mean if i'm not doing stand-up
i'm going to have time
yeah yeah so i was like okay and then
it changed from that to being just my
show and then
we were thinking about like you know
trying to introduce co-hosts or like
what's the word like audition co-host or
whatever yes
which is a bit of a nightmare yeah so i
was just like i don't even know who i
would
have that i i've been in la long enough
to like make a rapport with anybody you
know what i'm saying so
i just kind of was like let me just kick
the tires on this and just go and if you
don't like it man like
i'll do whatever you say well done
what's it called the josh potter show
yeah yeah thank you
yeah um it used to be called the roach
motel but we had a little thing
with the company that does that yeah
they don't there's a rosemary tail
company
yeah it's it's the thing that makes the
roaches the thing that traps the road
killer i don't know they call this a
little disc
oh wow they go in that little black disc
right yeah yeah yeah we had those in my
house
yeah yeah yeah no i've had i still got
him in my house
that's how i got the name no
[Laughter]
but uh yeah so we just the company i was
like [ __ ] this and i changed it to the
josh potter show because
i was like they're no one's going to
come after me for that one so yeah the
jjp show hopefully yeah
hell yeah so yeah i mean i'm digging it
it's 10 episodes deep right now
uh rob eiler is going to be the next
guest for this month of december
uh from the sopranos uh he's the
chillest dude in the world have you met
rob
no i don't know which which was rob rob
rob eiler
i'm not a big sopranos he's he's aj by
the way he's
i just started watching it a month ago
and did you like it
i love it okay hold on is it best show
you've ever seen i mean it's josh
can i say this can i say can i give that
a caveat to what you're about to say
okay
you have to put it in the spectrum of
the golden age of television because it
kicked it off it's a pioneer it's a
pioneer get all that
so it's part of the shows right now and
it and it competes with those shows
exactly how dare you what do you not
think it does mm-hmm what see he doesn't
i know i'm in the minority but i watch
it i'm like this [ __ ] is well you watch
a lot of you watch a lot of realities
i watch everything but you say watch
sopranos and i watch the world you
didn't watch something
did you like the wire more or less than
the surprise i like the wires the wire
more
i liked particular seasons of the wire
there are seasons of the wire that i
like
less than the support i agree with what
season is that um
yeah the late seasons get a little dicey
everyone should do this
no season two was dope but season two
was dope
that was an important season because
that was the connect season i agree okay
people [ __ ] on that the greeks
my favorite tv show is mad men i see
i've never seen it i didn't get into it
but
but i like the the the time period it's
in i like their outfits i like that they
smoke
yeah tom um don draper or you mean uh
but do you watch reality shows i don't i
do not i don't have cable but that's the
only dude you should go on married at
first sight
that's your go-to forever for everyone
that i know to go on the show
i wouldn't know if i wouldn't see him
the first time either so that's the
thing though
i mean like just take a couple times
yeah you would go you would do something
like married at first sound
uh i uh i don't know if i would do that
i wouldn't get married i mean if for a
tv show if they were giving me
a check you know maybe i would do it no
here's it here's
i'm the casting agent right okay i'm
married at first sight it's three
experts experts in love yeah and they
basically every city they go into they
go to certain cities
i just got done watching season would
you watch 11
7 in uh dallas and it's [ __ ] so
boring
don't watch season seven but um they
have these three
experts and so like 50 000 singles apply
to get chosen they pick four couples and
they
they pair you up based off what they
think is going to be a perfect
love life be you know perfect as can be
yeah and then you're married at first
sight and then you have oh my god
i did see this show yes this i saw the
one maybe the one that you sat on just
now the dallas one yeah
it might have been no it might have been
somewhere there's one there's one
episode
one on netflix yeah that season there's
a nine good season
that little white girl that married the
tall tall white dude yeah basketball
yeah what the [ __ ] he was he got he
lucked out i would have been
so awesome i've been stoked the first
night
yeah she was like but you know what made
me mad about what they did to him
is at the end of the show they kept like
prying at him like oh why'd you do it
i know i know i showed up for it he's
not gonna [ __ ] he does not care here's
what else is
interesting about me at first sight they
they don't pay much money i think they
get fifteen hundred dollars a week
and they they're interviewing the
producers like why do you pay you pay
him like [ __ ] they go
cause we don't want people coming on for
the wrong reasons that makes sense
because they all seemed pretty affable
yeah they're like if you come out here
you're literally looking for love not
trying to get famous or trying to make
money
that was i i you know i when you said
the show at first i was like no i never
watched that i had forgotten that i
started quarantine with that show like i
watched it on netflix so i watched on
netflix and i was like oh hell yeah and
me and my girl bought all the seasons
one through
i think 13 on amazon oh jesus yeah we
got problems
they have other um like i watched uh
that love on the spectrum
great show great that one was wonderful
but then there's another one that's like
a uk
version a uk version of love on the
spectrum
yep that's a little more like where
you're like i don't know if this is good
uk there was a couple on
love love on the spectrum where i was
like there were one dude i was like he
seems pretty
normal yeah like he was with a girl who
was on the spectrum but he was
trying to you could kind of tell he's
pretending this girl big titties
yeah i remember correct i feel like that
puts him on the spectrum though
yeah a little bit yeah i could tell he
had a [ __ ] together yeah yeah yeah
that's only one season yeah i think well
it's one or two seasons
there's a uk and there's australia
there's an australian one but the uk one
is la
it's not love on the spectrum it's
something else and it's a little more
dark it's like a little weirder oh i
like that
yeah what do you mean what do you mean
it's not dark in a cool way i don't know
it's
the one was sweet dark in a cool way
love the one the one
was sweet yeah it was like you felt
sweet and like you were like oh my god
like i'm having uh one of the uk
is weird the one in the uk like looks at
it in a clinical way
um it's a little more like
woof you know oh you were thinking dark
like drama
yeah that's what i was hoping yeah like
someone told me that they're like it's
dark and i was like showing the pitfalls
of being this uh type of person and
perhaps like
falling into into love perhaps and then
and it be blowing up in flames or
whatever or
the you know the horrible things that
could have arise from these
two people coming together like you know
i thought that's what they meant by dark
but it's not
well there's like there's that show born
this way where it's people with down
syndrome
and it's them trying to fit in the real
world and like get their [ __ ] together
and the i think there's three seasons or
something like that so the first season
you're like into it it's like it's like
real like sweet
but then it kind of gets dark yeah sad
because
it shows their limitations yes and you
realize oh they can't have a normal life
because
they have down syndrome another girl
gets with another down syndrome dude and
they get married
but then they want kids so then the
parents have to sit them down and
explain to them why they can't have kids
it's so heavy yeah that's terrible it's
like right
up here that's the kind of show with the
uk version where they kind of sit down
they're like you may never find love
yeah like that's such a bummer no you're
the downstairs one like they and they
want to go
be on their own like they don't want to
be with the parents
they want their independence they want
to drive they want yeah amazing yeah
it's amazing that they still have that
innate like instinct to want to like
be on their like you know what i mean
like yeah it's just what and there are
people
of completely able-bodied in mind who
don't have that
do you know what i mean yeah they still
live with their parents yeah yeah that's
why
they don't give a [ __ ] it's wild that
that can exist in a person who is
quote unquote mentally challenged yeah
when it doesn't
you know it doesn't exist in a
completely abled person like i wonder
what that is
it's explain to the audience that's
that's listening about like you said
something earlier
that uh two people who have down
syndrome can have kids explain that to
them well because their kids are gonna
have down syndrome oh yeah that's why
yeah and so they and they get you're
technically not allowed like if you they
can't
if you wanted to [ __ ] a down syndrome
girl it technically
can't
the first one was oh damn you use your
camera to find your glasses
what app is that i think he genuinely
does
and drops is so nice you just open up
your camera and zoom in dude
you're too nice i'll explain the world
dude thank you jv
josh's putting game on him
zoom in sorry about that
i'm like now with the down syndrome
community
there's certain [ __ ] that like i've
watched one time and i'm like i could
never watch it again like uh
what's that movie alpha dog oh my god
what a true story i could never
just choose i watched he had to kill a
dude wait wait
wait do you have kids way too [ __ ]
kids there's certain stuff where
if there's like child abuse i turn off
like automatically like i watch
that piece of [ __ ] ransom no this is a
documentary there's a documentary on
that dad that has his two kids
oh i got to the end i wanted to punch my
tv i
i don't send emails i send i don't give
yelp reviews i don't do any of that [ __ ]
i'm on social media
i wanted to [ __ ] send netflix and
email be like why would you give this
piece of [ __ ] the platform man
then why would this highlight with
certain horrible documentaries
dude how about that documentary this one
i'm glad they made it frankly because
it's so wild
but the abducted and plain sight [ __ ]
wait what
have you seen that documentary i bet
i've seen it
you've seen it you've talked about it
it's about the uh guy who kidnaps the
daughter and then like [ __ ] both the
parents
he has sex with both of the parents he
manipulates the whole family to this guy
where they allow him
to kidnap uh
i've never seen the guy infiltrates the
family to a degree in which
that's him like the mom makes the mom
fall in love no that's not him that's
the dad yeah
and then not only does he [ __ ] the mom
and make the mom fall in love with him
how are you doing yeah then
gets the dad yes to jerk his dick
yes in the comments jerk in his dick so
the the
the so the dad we need to talk he's like
right get my car
like we need to [ __ ] talk he's like
cool get in my car the dude's so good at
this hustle i don't know what is the
[ __ ] drive he's jacking the dab
yeah so he's a con artist whatever 100
very late he's [ __ ] good he put all
this effort in just to [ __ ]
this kid and he like then he has this
elaborate roost to get the kid on board
like oh it's nuts he like makes her
think that she's abducted by
aliens are these people or no they're
they're all talking in the documentary
which i found
they're all talking even the guy i met
the producer of that
film and she's told me that um
the dad never divulged any of that in
the pre-interviews
he just spilled that out on camera
that's why there's not really a
follow-up there because they didn't know
that he was going to say that they're
like
and then he just broke down wow so they
were like uh what do we
do now there's been some crazy this got
me through this quarantine like do you
see
jinx no what's that oh no i did see that
that's i saw that a while jinx he
so spoiler in three two one listen it's
history so suck these nuts yeah but he's
basically killing
them he's killing women yeah like he has
a wife
kills her in germany comes here kills
her and they can't figure it out
then at the end of the interview again
spoiler in three two one
at the end of the they're doing like you
know the closing interviews yeah
he goes to the bathroom leaves his mic
on and he's an old guy now
and he's talking to himself and he goes
did i kill those people of course i
killed those [ __ ] people
he's honestly he's miked up and forgot
about it while he's pissing yeah
that's how that that's like the doctor
like the trump grabbed my [ __ ]
yeah nuts dude yeah like you're like wow
those live mics man
you see that one what about the uh
mike's
db cooper you know that one
you know db cooper the guy that [ __ ]
hijacked the plane
stole all the money you don't know that
one what's up i think they had him on
dateline what documentary no they don't
know who they don't know
where the guy is is this yeah he just
disappeared no they might
my dad used to tell me about this guy he
used to be like oh you see a bag on the
side of the road you'd be like up db
cooper that's not the guy in daylight
nbc
none of you guys have heard of i've
heard of him yeah he's the guy it's like
it's like a folklore story yeah
like so [ __ ] dude basically hijacks a
plane
steal some money whatever the plane was
going from reno to
seattle or something like that and then
he uh he uh
what do you call it skydives parachutes
out of the plane and never been found
did he jack the pilot off the co-pilot
off he he didn't get that because this
doesn't sound as good as the one yeah
did he chat at all did he get the pilot
to steal the plan
i wanted to get i'm like in that
documentary though i could not believe
they did not follow up on that's why i
was so like how do you not
talk about this more and it was because
of the fact that he leaked it out but i
was like
did he spit on his hand did he [ __ ]
what happened here you know what i mean
like
but you're watching it's mine like
you're like wait why
you gotta rewind you go you just [ __ ]
say yeah i think he said because he's
just like
yeah you when we went for a drive and
then you're like wait
you don't even see it come normally you
see that train coming down the chair
yeah
so the kidnapper that's my point i'm
trying to do this too by the way so i
might not have all your answers okay
okay so let me just again for the
audience listen so we're inside the car
right right and i got the gun we didn't
have a gun he just like hide himself
they were family friends this guy he
infiltrated enough were like they were
inviting him over
he had a wife too yeah and they were
inviting his family over for
barbecues picnics things like that and
then he started [ __ ] the wife she
fell in love with him okay that was his
first tactic okay and then he confronted
about the wife and his inappropriate
relationship with his daughter because
he was coming over and like
can i lay with jessica and they would
allow it and they were no they were
yes they would they'd be like oh it's
uncle it's uncle terry or whatever
yeah whatever his [ __ ] name okay and
uh so then the dad was like there's
something weird here and
he was more concerned i think about his
wife than his daughter at the time
and he went for a drive with him and
then i don't remember
what the words were that the dad used to
describe this moment leading up to it
but eventually basically it went from
being like we were in a drive and
all of a sudden and i was like no he's
not going to tell me he [ __ ] this dude
right yeah and then he goes like
basically he's like
i forget how he described the hand job
but he described a hand job yeah
essentially yeah
uncle tony gave him a hand job yeah so
he and then he just breaks down and
cries and
apparently he never admitted that to
anybody before yeah
the yeah the people shooting it were
like what yeah they're like dude
they did all these pre-interviews he got
with that daughter
what oh yeah he got what the whole
family got with the entire family
including the dad
and the daughter's alive now yeah she
she talks in the documentary is she hot
uh today i don't know that's her that's
her that's her yeah
he's dead i believe and he's like pretty
handsome looking he looks like a charmer
i mean like that's not there i mean
that's when he died
well back in the day though yeah i mean
he must have like
or these people are so [ __ ] dumb
they're idiots well first of all
a grown man coming over to lay with your
daughter but an entire family
you gotta wonder what kind of game he
spent there what where does this take
place
you know what i mean middle america hey
hey man watch the doc though you know
yeah hey spoil yeah you just threw two
ones well you got a little spoiler you
have questions
yeah it makes you want to watch it more
right yeah and i can't tell you anything
that doesn't make you want to watch this
yeah because there's no answers to it
we're all sitting here going like do you
see don't [ __ ] with cats i did not watch
that yet
is that good too i'll check that out i
need some more corn quarantine's ramping
up a couple months i don't know if you
guys heard i need a couple of
recommendations
you gotta watch sneaky peek just in l.a
is that a documentary yeah
nope that's a show that's a show though
right but we should i mean we talk about
kind artists kind of
just give me a documentary oh
documentary of course
i'll give you documentary i love last
names to watch that [ __ ] i bought
youtube tv just to watch the [ __ ] yeah
yeah what is it so well done
oh my god you know what i walked away
with can i tell you a controversial
opinion i have about that yeah
no i'm i'm not gonna i'm not gonna take
a side on that debate
uh necessarily but i'm gonna tell you
this isaiah thomas is my [ __ ] goat
talk that talk here jp no
the weeks that have come out since
the documentary yep isaiah is like i
don't even know jordan thought of me
that way
totally bitching them out don't you
think jordan's on there like
i just i t is like a piece of [ __ ] he
said he beat what i mean
he cried he was all [ __ ] about i i
said that's true
he did get him off the olympic team and
he's still and he's still holding that
crazy like i don't care what you say
about him today
i still hate him or whatever yeah yeah
that's it i didn't know you
i don't even think about michael jordan
also also we can we can say isaiah be
michael jordan
he'd be larry bird well this is what he
said he goes i wasn't chasing michael
jordan michael jordan was chasing
me oh say that again copy that say i was
chasing
magic i was chasing bird i was chasing
branches
chasing the whole world the bronzer and
he's just he's doing all the things
though i mean you gotta give him
credit he's doing all the statistical
yeah you know what i mean like was
jordan the complete package like lebron
i don't know
no he wasn't this is i mean i know what
you're gonna say yeah yeah right
[Laughter]
yeah it is interesting yeah isaiah was
like i wasn't even thinking about it
yeah he he just jordan
he's like yeah and then he ranked his
top five opponents that he faced and he
goes like at the end
at the he was like magic uh
he like named four people and then he
was like i guess michael
yeah he was like because he's so smart i
guess i guess michael yeah
i'll throw him in there yeah and i love
how jordan's like i didn't get him
kicked off the team no even brought it
out to me and then the guy in charge
i was like no he called me so i learned
how to really
let you know mj is alive i like that
he's competitive to the point of like
boom or bust but also it makes him a bit
of a [ __ ]
he is a [ __ ] yeah it's it's like a
[ __ ]
no no lebron doesn't i don't think
lebron's as competitive as
michael jordan michael jordan was like
fighting with that [ __ ]
whack-out security guard he had or
whatever
yeah i thought that was i thought they
should put on the white face
that
jordan seems exhausting to hang out with
yeah exactly like exhausted like uh
you played cards and he lost he'd keep
you up all night until he can't go
golfing with him can't go golfing
you heard what he uh uh him and um uh
what's the guy named kevin mchale
yeah golf right before the game yeah and
kevin beat him out all his money
the next game jordan dropped 63 points
well how how about when uh
madonna was hooking up with uh dennis
rodman
and lebron i'm sorry jordan was in the
lobby
and he thought she was coming for him
but she was coming to see dennis
that must have been a competition that
he couldn't even fathom anything yeah do
you know what i'm saying that's not a
dice game that's not golf really yeah i
thought jordan was married at the time
it didn't make it how about yeah hey
welcome to professional sports
we're just [ __ ] off on malik hey wait
a second i thought he was married that's
against the rules
that's weird nba players don't do that
nerd alert
josh i want to apologize and if tom
doesn't do that podcast with you i got a
[ __ ] note
are you guys happy that with the nba
opening up and with the new rules and
they don't have stadiums
oh you mean uh coming up in the next
season here yeah i don't i didn't read
anything about it all the time
i don't have people in the stadiums to
the playhouse yeah that's what fauci
said
oh seriously yeah they're not because
the season starts in this month dude
yeah but next year they start on
christmas right yeah starts on christmas
but the real season i'm starting to
martin luther king day
nhl is kind of like we don't even know
what's going like nhl has they're like
maybe new year's
have we heard about them no they they
they sincerely haven't given
a [ __ ] i i care but i mean they haven't
given uh
so i mean we i mean we have big hockey
town i love hockey but it's like
the nhl is such a shitty run league it's
like
i was paying attention to nhl when they
had this black guy in there on the cover
of the espn
and he was butt naked but he had like
skates on i was like who is this pk
subban yeah okay is he good is he
killing hell yeah dude there's a bunch
of black guys that are good in there oh
vander kane evander kane's the man he
used to play for the sabers
and uh spk right there
i wouldn't say if he's on the devils now
yeah would you what's that you say a
bunch of black guys are good
i'd say i'd say i'd say there's like
there's like
it's the one sport white guys still have
yeah it's the only sport we have
it is and uh europeans and uh how many
black dudes are in it
i i mean i don't know the number i don't
know the number i mean but more than
more
more than there were i'd say a handful
like you said there's there's
some amount of time pk subban is a huge
start
of black guys right there yeah i mean i
there was a time that's ever there was a
time
there was a time when the sabres had
four which is unheard of
in the 90s yeah like white guys are just
you white guys in europeans are one of
their
guys one of the black people don't get
skates and go this shit's kind of cool
there was a black dude there's a guy i
mean he follows me on twitter i've only
communicated i i'm i'm a big
savers guy okay and so he played for the
savers his name is roman
nader oh sounds good ndur he was born in
africa okay and plays in the nhl
or played in the nhl in the 90s how did
he train he
his father was like i forgot his father
did but he moved him to canada and so
like that's what happened
he moved he was an immigrant to canada
and became a star
not a st he was never a star i'll say
that but he he went to the nhl i mean he
was like a fighter
checker he was an enforcer yeah he was
enforced
he's trying to tell you he was getting
violent when we learned how to skate
dude i [ __ ]
i'm telling you the second you level up
it's over it'll be the nba all over
again dude now dude
i'm talking are they good or do they
like great enforcers like dude that's
not like that
is a scorer a goal scorer yeah he's like
huge i mean like he's like a [ __ ]
superstar evander kane's a huge goal
scorer yeah you don't realize
as far as most dominant in the sport
ever wayne gretzky is probably the most
dominant
by far hands-down bar none in any sport
and you don't need crosby no wayne
gretzky i mean gretzky get out of their
level dog
so here's the you can't crosstalk the
thing about just compared like
okay the thing again you're asking ap
science questions yeah yeah yeah
i don't know i was just googling you
just compared like alonzo ball to like
[ __ ]
goals you don't realize how big of a
deal wayne gretzky is you forget and
then i went to edmonton to do shows
and we had some friends there that work
for the oilers and like hey you want to
do a tour i'm like sure i guess
sounds boring was not boring in edmonton
stadium dude it was dope we got to see
their practice
see them go on the ice they got some
baller there i forget who their
stud player is [ __ ] uh baller dude
what's uh we drafted
thank you second and the i forget the
[ __ ] guys i'm
blanking because of the world no no no
we drafted jack eichel second that year
and they drafted who's first type type
in edmonds
i i cast this man out of my mind because
we lost the first round pictures
and i was like [ __ ] him we got jack
michael i like jack michael better
who the [ __ ] is it what's this lineup
what's it you said starting lineup no
just no no edmonton number one draft
pick
he's like a generational player i can't
believe i'm blanking on his game
david connor mcdavid oh my god i'm such
a [ __ ]
the guy looks like he from shameless
that guy he's like
all hockey players look like kids which
is i don't know i think that
that edmonton oilers is literally a
generation of wayne gretzky when he's
like
seven dude it's insane and wayne gretzky
looks like a [ __ ]
like you you see you two see wayne
gretzky i'd imagine you'd be like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] like when he's in his time
you know what i mean like show wayne
gretzky in his prime like back in the
edmonton oilers days like
he looks like a kid yeah this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're stuck at home you put on
the quarantine 25
you like the box you like the kickbox
but you can't get to the gym
i got you covered fam bring the gym to
you bring the fight gym to you with
fight camp
provides boxing kickboxing workouts
right from your living room you get all
the gear man that provides you with all
the gear that you need
whatever you need boxing gloves bags
hand wraps
you download the app next thing you know
you're freaking mike tyson
son get it while you can right now it's
the perfect holiday gift too
fight camp is the perfect gift for
anyone that wants to take the fitness to
the next
level all right don't go to the gym
anymore don't risk it do it from your
crib man fight camp is the gift
that keeps on giving and giving means
getting in shape
it's in for the entire family man and
don't worry about it
there's flexible financing for fight
camp for as low as zero apr
right now zero dollars down right now is
limit time holiday offer get free
shipping and a gift valued up to 109
with every fight camp package just go to
join the
just go to joinfightcamp.com fighter
that's right get free shipping and a
gift valued up to 109
with your purchase bring authentic
boxing kickboxing gym right to your crib
with fight camp
to get your free gift just go to
joinfightcamp.com
fighter join fightcamp.com fighter he
looks like a kid
yeah this [ __ ] [ __ ] but he's like
he's a beast and you know what they had
back there hot daughter
they had two enforcers mcsorley and guys
on his lines
that would beat the [ __ ] out of people
that would [ __ ] with if they touched him
now crosby you brought up cindy crosby
he doesn't have that so he gets
concussions he's [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
he has to try and
fight guys you see cindy crosby getting
so mad that he has to fight
because no one does it for him because
they got rid of fighting
they got rid of him so sidney crosby and
alex trump uh what's his name
uh
there it is so that's like jordan versus
lebron kind of little thing
no it's more like um it'd be more like
uh lebron and steph curry or like brady
versus manning okay i guess that's the
best way i can compare it
because they're playing at the same time
and they're both in their prime at the
same time yeah
okay so even one of them or on wayne
crosby's
hurt neither of them are on wayne
gretzky's level not even close
like he is ascending above now he's in
his older age but i mean he won how many
cups and
he's the boss can only won one cup but
he had a long layoff where he
concussions he like he would get because
he didn't have any enough force no
montreal yeah but you look at his stat
it's as far as dominant i mean he is
he's the best ever leaps and bounds
above yeah because he won a bunch in
them two in england
yeah i want to say maybe three and they
had messier on that team too right
which one's at the rangers uh oh when he
won the rangers then hell yeah that was
like a
super team i mean i was like richter i
mean that was like the 90s that was
that was pretty dope i mean i wouldn't
mind the rangers being good again they
got the number one overall pick this
year so
hopefully they'll be so your balls deep
in hockey i love hockey yeah
but i mean it's it's a what's egregious
and it's made me
like kind of repel in the last few years
is that the sabers organization
is run terribly even though it's run by
the same people running the bills right
now
and hockey in general is run terribly
the nhl is a [ __ ] league well just look
how they handled covet they didn't have
any cases or anything like that they
went to canada to quarantine and like
bubble out
but they didn't know what they were
doing the draft
lottery came out before the playoffs so
weird
yeah and like multiple teams who were in
the playoffs were eligible for the
number one pick
the sabres meanwhile were the eighth
overall yeah there's just no playing we
weren't even in the playoffs yeah like
it's [ __ ] brutal and no one's talked
about nhl really either
no i mean it's really just gone because
people were kind of like whatever
yeah and the way that the nba has
counteracted their low ratings and
things like that culturally
the nhl has none of that you know what i
mean like the nba
they got the lowest ratings they got
ever in these playoffs or whatever i
think that's
politics too they went right too far
awoke yes
but it doesn't matter they'll survive
because of the fact that culturally
they're more relevant than the nhl will
ever be yeah not even close
yeah it's not even anywhere near it are
you a big fighting fan
i don't watch mma and stuff like that i
don't i and it's weird like
i don't know why but i just i'll watch
it when like a big one's on like one
that
is in the zeitgeist of the world it's
not your cup of tea but it's just not
like i don't
follow all the details of it do you know
what i mean like in terms of like i do
other like footballs i'd say my one
number one okay and then number two
would be probably
now it's baseball i'm not gonna lie dude
oh cause the dodgers won
it's just the last couple years the way
that it's gone because i've just been so
pissed off at
[ __ ] the saber it used to be hockey
but it's gone it's gone to baseball
follow baseball way more than hockey now
interesting okay
well i'm sorry i don't know
basketball is my distant fourth but i
still love it i i actually
joined a fantasy basketball league this
year so that i could
pay attention learn about it okay and
learn i feel like basketball does a good
job like with their stars like we know
that all
there's just less players though that's
the thing like compared to think about
it football has 53 men rosters yeah
how many people are 12 people on a
basketball team yeah well 15
15. yeah and then a a hockey team even
think about this
a hockey team is comprised of
five players on four lines so that's 20
starters right there you know what i
mean because they're go they're playing
like
a minute and a half two minutes at a
stint and then they switch off
yeah they sprint they do like line
changes
that's why there's so many dudes and but
it is it's like basketball and that's
five on five
but they do line changes so frequently
amongst the action where it's like you
know they got amongst four four lines
there so there's 20
combinations coming in i think
basketball too they don't have a helmet
on there's no pads so it's like what you
see you see on the street too
sure and they're like legitimate
superstars
face yeah yeah brand recognition like
they're
crushing it yo didn't uh what'd you call
play for
uh oj oh the [ __ ] yeah
yeah his name's still on our wall of
fame we don't give a [ __ ] that he killed
anybody
josh god damn josh
he didn't kill anybody who's playing for
the bills
i mean well yeah a very very good point
oh he was already out right
no he was way i mean that's what like
somebody was somebody
it was i was on dr drew's show and he
was like you were a little kid when oj
played for the bills and i was like well
how old do you think i [ __ ] am bro
like all right they played for the bills
in 69.
i was like six when he murdered his wife
yeah i mean like
what are you talking about it's weird
usc pulled all the [ __ ] too it's like
well
we didn't pull anything no nor should
you because it's also like
when he was playing for you he did his
job you get this before he got arrested
for the vegas thing though like stealing
his memorabilia
the time he actually went to jail he was
coming to bill's games
oh wow and he and people were like do we
bring them through the
i had a media pass at the time so like i
was like up in the press box like [ __ ]
like that
and they were bringing them around and
no one really knew how to like react to
it
you know everyone's kind of like this is
weird
yeah do you give them a hug you go like
do i am i going to be seen like being
like what's up
mr simpson you know like did i take a
selfie on the ground have you met him
this was back in
i never got to meet him but this is back
in like 08 09
07. like i before he got arrested i
can't remember the exact
but van miller was still the this must
have been earlier than that actually
because
van miller's last year was 04. so i
i had just started producing the games
for our station
and van miller i'll never forget this
saw oj coming to the press box and was
like get him the [ __ ] out of here
like this old man this old broadcasting
legend who called oj simpson's games
wow who is like uh uh no but i
i hate it right but like uh he he was
like he wouldn't stand for it he
wouldn't stand for him being around
the press box he's like get him out of
here i mean depending how you feel about
it makes sense yeah no it does make
sense
it was just funny because this guy's so
like nonchalant and like he
every time i met him before he passed i
was like
he would joke around and like have a dad
joke for you blah blah but when he saw
oj i never saw a man so angry
interesting it was wild because he felt
like he felt betrayed
he got a murderer well he murdered two
people yeah he was upset about that
we would allow him to like be a part of
this organization yeah
like it's such a dark cloud like you
can't have it you know
it was wild well you but back to your
usc point uh i think usc
i think they're obligated as a college
because you remember what they did with
reggie bush took away their his
that's [ __ ] they brought him back
though right that makes them they
brought it back they brought him back
but he made it
how many years he was on the bills for a
second yeah that's right he's on the
bills
yeah that's right yeah damn it was the
best it just makes no sense
for who reggie because they're taking
money the money he's taking some cake
which is so dumb it's so stupid everyone
i take money too everyone's taken
everyone these strong
college kids and that's like he got he
just got caught yeah he and he was like
a
poster boy you know he was [ __ ]
kardashian and he was like
i forget when the saints drafted him oh
he won a
champion uh he dropped him in 2006. no i
forget
where in the draft though like first
round first round oh yeah yeah
mary used to come out on the saints with
the bat and uh yeah the playoffs yeah
he got us one super bowl yeah man that's
wild
it's crazy it's crazy the reggie bush
and matt liner
i believe we're on the bills around the
same time yeah that's nuts
isn't that crazy and they both got like
i think reggie bush stuck on as a
special teams guy
and matt liner got cut reggie bush they
didn't at the time the
nfl didn't know what to do with him now
if he came out now he'd be a gadget dude
he'd be a monster yeah like he'd be like
a mccaffrey like
or like to do with a receiver out of the
backfield like catching passes
yeah like the saints would they do now
with a camaro whatever
yeah yeah like but at the time he was
like this slash
he could have been the taste some hill
of that yeah dude they just didn't know
what to do with him because you can't
just put him in the backfield
yeah so if he would have came out now
he'd have such a better career
yeah it's weird how the game evolves
like that you see guys that are like
gadget dudes
and you're like holy [ __ ] if he was in
this like pat white if pat white was
taysom hill
he could have lit it up oh i know it's
very strange it's
football's such a great sport for the
fact that
you get so few reps and chances like you
think about it like
there's 86 hockey games there's a
hundred and
million baseball games there's 17
football games a year damn you know what
i mean i didn't know that
you didn't know that no i don't want you
there's 17 you get
i mean games no as a football player you
get
so few chances if you have a 10-year
career you played in
170 games which is that's as many as a
baseball players
plays in one season almost you know is
it because they take a lot more contact
though
i i mean well they've scheduled that
that's just the way the support is just
the way the sport works it's
just 17 games a year but and they're
maybe trying to expand it which is crazy
but
it's just you think about that part of
it and you're like a
guy who made it to the pros could have
played in
five games and been successful and still
made a bazillion dollars
yeah yeah but he played in five games
but there's also guys like terrell davis
who's a hall of famer
only had like really a f i mean they say
like four years
but four years yeah yeah yeah like four
cents that's what i'm saying and he's a
hall of famer
yeah four years of your life it's like
the beatles that ain't [ __ ]
yeah yeah that that's nothing it's crazy
to think about that i think it's the
popularity thing like
and it goes to my next question so nfl
films
best film ever with the nfl was that's
wonderful let me give it sunday
yeah i thought you were talking about
football
just in case something monumental
happens well they did a lot for the
patriots remember the super bowl
winnings
that's all that you saw because that was
the monumental things but they go
they'll tape everything everything
seriously guys just in case nonstop if
there's a crazy moment
where it's like some unearth
earth-shattering moment
let's say nfl phones has it do you know
what i mean from
from jump back in the 70s the guy who
started passed away but they had a whole
arm
of just old school [ __ ] and he's on the
nfl network yeah
okay but what was your you're talking
about football you were talking about
like movies yeah movies but i'm saying
and you saying uh in the chat you make
sure you're in the big
like over there in the field i'm not
over there in the streets i'm not sure
sure sure uh what's the
nhl movie it sucks we all all we got is
mighty ducks
you watch mighty ducks nowadays yes
awful dog shots oh it doesn't hold up
it's still going
oh it's corny as [ __ ] now you go like
how did i even like this when i was like
trying to think
yeah it's a disney thing yeah like
there's not a great miracle miracle on
ice
that's a good one because it's about
that americans being the russians yeah
yeah that's back in the night
shot snapshot you've seen that shot's
good but it's like campy it's like about
enforcers and stuff
you know what's a good documentary about
hockey is
uh enforcers one yes what the [ __ ] the
last something or other it's like
there's a guy there's a guy in it that
he's like if i could go back and do it
all again
i would do it with more fire and you're
like oh my god it makes your dick harder
there's a there's a dog it's all about
the last about is it this
ice guardians ice guardians yeah and
it's it it gives you
it's it gives you the significance of
fighting in the sport and why it's
important
and why the fact that they're trying to
get rid of it is stupid they they're
trying to get rid of it because of
concussions
which in fact it actually prevents
concussions more than it causes
concussions believe it or not
because they're fighting in a way and
you know this is a fighter probably
they're on skates they got
loose jerseys and [ __ ] they're never
gonna clock each other to the point
where like
anyone's gonna get any real like maybe
on occasion but no one's gonna
really get significant brain they're
settling their differences out with
exactly instead of taking out what you
know meanwhile
if they take it out on a star and
they're decking them into the corner
yeah they're gonna [ __ ] give them
brain more damage yeah then
they would get in a fight it's all about
optics right especially in this
woke world where right where they're
they're saying you're gonna allow these
guys to fight but like
the mayhem you know that happened in the
nba yeah you know
listen to palestine yeah that [ __ ] oh
yeah nba was back
yeah that was with like fans and [ __ ]
right yeah i mean that's knocked out
that's just yeah
yeah that's different than two dudes on
the like that's part like the ref
actually
stands there and lets them square off
and settle it and then once it's settled
it's a moment it's
over and it's done because no one's
gonna [ __ ] with that guy again yep
you know now hear me out yeah
that's why i don't know why more i'm not
this is maybe derogatory but i don't
know why more black people aren't into
hockey there's fighting and it's illegal
yeah well those who learn how to skate
on ice because we're not a skate on like
and there's a ton of white people to
beat the [ __ ] out of well
well yeah i mean i
didn't know this is a race thing is all
i'm saying i had an enforcer
at the time for the avalanche forget his
name but he came to me because we're
with the same trainer lauren
landau shout out to lauren he came to me
he's like uh i want you to help me work
on technique
interesting and i was like you're on the
ice dudes it's like it's just
that's not what i do yeah your footing's
all weird like you got a grip there's
drowsy in a way
dude you gotta that's the way they do it
they gotta they there's a strategy your
strategy grip and grip [ __ ] rip like
yes you pull them in
and he was a he was a big obvious it's
so funny when you see them guys just
time it
oh man they want to kick each other out
they'll watch how about you get on a
i'm going to key you onto an instagram
account okay hockey fights
oh hold on just [ __ ] go to that
instagram account
have you ever seen the hockey like the
real hockey i've never really this dude
i don't know his job was an enforcer so
you know like
on uh happy uh happy gilmore yeah yeah
how he was like
he was the most technical dude but he
could do some stuff well but he was like
[ __ ] dudes up yeah like that's
there's real guys like that there's a
guy from buffalo
rob ray who i grew up watching he kind
of dated my cousin
hell yeah and uh kind of means they've
hooked up with your coach he just [ __ ]
my cousin
thank you for coming
yeah and so this guy has a rule named
after him because he used to go out on
the ice now
a jersey on the nhl you have equipment
under it right pajama chip
you have strap in the back that like
attaches to that
you got like some snaps up here that
attaches your jersey so that it's
attached to the equipment
yeah he would leave all that [ __ ] loose
so that when you fought him and you grab
his jersey
he could slip out of it and he'd be
completely shirtless
and fight a dude shirtless so they
couldn't grab him and he would beat the
[ __ ] out of dudes if you just type in
rob ray fight it'll be him shirtless
fighting a dude and they had to make a
robbery rule that if your shirt comes
off in a fight it's
legitimately like you get like a game
misconduct or something
now here's what's a bummer because when
you're a kid and you want to play hockey
you want to see wayne gretzky you want
to be the guy scoring all the goals
and there comes a point in your career
where the coach goes hey come here
so you're never going to be that guy
you're never going to be the headlining
comic
you're going to be the guy that goes
after their
fight he's beating the [ __ ] out of this
guy he's not even taking his jersey off
yet oh
because that's not the fastest you're
not like you're not
but here's the thing you're not the
pretty boy what are you doing
the helmet's only like it's like a the
leather football helmet like it's
nothing
it's like a bike helmet rob ray was this
[ __ ] dude i remember
rob race 32 right there in the blue he's
beating up a philadelphia flyer dave
brown with [ __ ]
dirty philadelphia flyers wait is this
about that
watch see how loose his jersey is right
now already what is it sean william
scott isn't that a hockey movie he's in
he's in goon yeah yeah yeah that's what
this is about he rob ray was a goon
these are goons these guys that fight
see he took his shirt off but as a kid i
collected eric
lindros am i going live eric lindros
[ __ ] i [ __ ] hate eric
he was he's my arch-nemesis as a kid so
they let him fight until they get to the
ground pretty much
they'll let him let him go for a while
yeah like kind of both exhausted
here comes his jersey it's all the way
off he wants it yeah he every time he
wanted it
josh i'm not gonna go live with this
fight no no he's coming back here it is
oh oh oh yeah it's over dog he's gonna
he's knocked some
some [ __ ] out dude no dudes are
getting knocked out yeah him and ty domi
all the time right there all right
went at this is tied me on the [ __ ]
winnipeg jets
yeah these two are two of the best
fighters ever in the history of time
and they would battle dude they were
when
some of the enforcers are are bigger
than me some of them are [ __ ] big
dude yeah yeah
six six some feet again sometimes you
know their goal is to be wayne gretzky
at some point in the career it has to be
heartbreaking
it doesn't become your goal because
eventually you go to juniors you go to
minor leagues and you know what you are
yeah and you're waiting to be called up
so you can protect the star
yeah you get signed to the team that's
got the biggest star
you know you're gonna that's your job
yeah back in the 90s
that documentary the enforcer talks
about he goes dude my life was terrible
because
i'd be at the movie theater my kid
knowing
tomorrow like i'm not scoring the goals
like i gotta fight this
monster you know you're going into a
game you gotta squirt off like a ufc
fighter like you're trying to enjoy life
but you know
tomorrow so you're [ __ ] scrapping but
i wanna i mean you've been in the ring
so you know this
like you when you were in the ufc you
knew you were
gonna fight the guy in the nhl they
didn't know like they're like is this
situation gonna arise so they had to
like
but you know you're they're just yeah
like if they say
so there's a specific guy for that yeah
often times they'll be like we don't
have any threats this week you're gonna
be scratched
go watch it from the [ __ ] box yep but
then they're like
hey you're gonna be dressing tonight and
you're going like all right let's take
the roster out and see who's out here
oh wow there's a lot of times like you
know they're enforcers so you know who
you're going against and they would have
battles dude yeah okay so that's what
rob ray and ty dominic so
so those enforcers like they know
exactly who they're fighting
how tough the guy is so the guy's
talking about like the stress he was
under
all the time because you knew it was
impending okay they didn't know when it
was
exhausting so beyond the fighting part
what are they doing like
on the ice like in when the games
they're keeping people in check so that
like their star
say the star is you know in front of the
net trying to score
if one of the defenders comes in and
jacks them that guy's coming in and
giving you [ __ ] heat for that
yes like or if you [ __ ] with the goalie
like you ever seen if you [ __ ] with the
goalie yeah you're [ __ ] the best
yeah like someone like runs into the
goalie and the guy who pushes them
you'll see homeboy the unfortunate come
from all the other
rules and your tree rules and [ __ ] them
up yeah
that's the best
how is it how is it like going to a live
nhl game
dude it's the best job savers game [ __ ]
it's
back again i'm not like i won't watch
hockey on tv
in live first it's hands down besides
ufc unbiased
but as far as live sports island it's
the best sport you can watch
if you want to go on a date with your
girl yeah [ __ ] nfl [ __ ]
nba yeah nhl is the best in person sport
to watch
the checks are brutal get there the
checks on the ice you'll see how
talented they are
on the ice it's mind-blowing it's
[ __ ] nuts how good they are on ice
it's nuts you've been to the games oh
yeah because you remember i grew up
colorado avenue yeah yeah foreign dude
that was back in the day that was it i
remember
my dad i'll never forget this my dad
because it was the avalanche and the
detroit red wings
were like they were that was the scrap
and it was the biggest ticket
in all of the land and some dude gave my
dad uh
floor basey ice ringside tickets
and my dad goes you want to go i'm like
[ __ ] yeah we're going some dude off my
dad i think
five thousand dollars a ticket wouldn't
have a lot of money i'm like dude
dad [ __ ] sell them no way
he's like the experience you're gonna
get from this is priceless
and i was like you're out of your room
that's beautiful he bought me a patrick
uh uh yeah uh patrick white jersey
he had a fordsburg jersey on i will
never forget it
it was on f i have a moment like that
real too
i think that's why i'm so passionate now
yeah it was on
real dude my dad when i was a kid took
me to i was a giant i was like a sabers
not to the point where i was like
keeping stats and notebooks and [ __ ]
like this is when i between the age of
like 11
to 16 i was obsessed watch every [ __ ]
game i had no life no girls you know
what i'm saying like you're not going
out
so you just watch exactly nerd alert i
was watching every [ __ ] game
same spot of the house you know and my
dad took me to the year we went to the
stanley cup in 99
my dad took me to the series we played
against toronto in the playoffs
all the home games it was [ __ ] i'll
never forget it i can't even thank my
dad enough for doing that yeah isn't it
weird though certain moments like
i will never got it from like a guy at
work like yeah so wild you know i'll
never forget that i remember the guy
all dads was around and [ __ ] yes
and the dad part yeah yeah that was a
real
white boy yeah what's it like i mean
honestly
i'm telling you i will never forget i
remember the guy goes what ticket you
got my dad
shows him and the guy goes i'll give you
five grand a piece for him like that's
why
dude let's we're going scissors yeah
[ __ ] sell those and
we needed the money
my dad [ __ ] around on my mom a [ __ ]
ton but
[Laughter]
he took me to a lot of hockey games
remember he used to take me on the
subway to the i remember going downtown
like as a child like
four or five years old and he used to
take me when i was young enough where he
could get me in for free
because he just lied and said sit on the
lap or whatever because i was small i
was a tiny kid
even when i was five so like he would be
like he's two
yeah you know what i mean like that kind
of [ __ ] and i'd be like i'm five and
you'd be like shut up
shut your face oh my dad used to do like
kind stuff like that yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
we used to go through like six flags and
he'll put me in a wheelchair
i felt like tom cruise because when we
had those tickets you were allowed to go
in this vip area where there's food and
the food was ridiculous
what it was so cool man some of the best
swimmers i have is hockey
hockey which is so weird i never talk
about hockey until you came it's so fun
dude i love it i wish the sabres were
better i wish the sport was in a better
place king the kings are good though too
it's funny you're not getting any more
yeah funny because uh l.a right
if the team's good like that's the thing
to go to yeah when the kings were good
that was the ticket in town it's so you
know what i found weird
when i was 2018 i went to a sabres game
um it was like the daytime it was always
like saturday at 1pm or something
i couldn't believe how many latino
people were hockey fans oh yeah
it was crazy like in buffalo you don't
see that you know what i'm saying that's
all so you're like
whoa this is weird you know it's cool
but it's weird all right let's go some
current events what do you got sure yeah
shout out to hockey
if we can convert you to hockey
i'm trying okay so over in dallas there
is a restaurant that is known for
modern-day comfort food and it's a
black-owned business who primarily
caters to
a black clientele you make like soul
food yeah they make soul food like
elevated soul food
and there is a clip of the restaurant
owner going off on his patrons
and it's mostly women he's basically
saying
if you're gonna twerk in my restaurant
get the [ __ ] out because i guess they
were playing megan the stallion there
was
a group who was playing it was the the
restaurant was playing megan the
stallion yeah would you what do you
think
i hear that i start twerking that's the
second thing i don't know
stallion you have to shake your ass i
saw this story
the same thing yada yada
a little bit getting a little rowdy but
it doesn't seem like they're bothering
anyone but this restaurant owner saw
was super mad goes off on them saying
like this is why black people can't have
nice things
he goes off he's black also though yeah
he just wanted to clarify
so black people can have somewhere nice
to go to okay
somewhere where we can feel good about
ourselves
does he have a short he tells his own dj
to stop the music
with short sleeves on it looks like it
yep
can i tell you next yeah take it to
prime take it to pink
don't bring it here because we're a
restaurant
75 percent of my customers are ladies
and i'm not mean to show respect for
themselves for how they carry themselves
here so how can i tell the men to
respect themselves and you guys are
talking on last year if you want to do
it give the [ __ ] out my restaurant
oh wow yeah [ __ ] but but hold on
it is a point but that get the [ __ ] out
was kind of like
we were talking we were talking sopranos
earlier this guy
is the black artie buco yeah he ain't
having it
i love artibuco too but this guy doesn't
know
what he's doing he [ __ ] up in the fact
that
listen he in that clip he told his own
dj shut the music down
yeah he brought the dj and paid him to
be there
but also to play make the stand that's
what i'm saying which you heard the
stanley cup
[Music]
uh don't you think that the guy just did
that to get exposure
no because this is not awesome no no
because the younger audience are never
no people are mad about this yeah but
this guy [ __ ] up his yelp reviews i
bet are awful now like this ain't the
look man he had to
make an apology of course now like he
did now if they were twerking to like
beethoven or something yes like i wanna
just say his point like you're gonna
play that like he wants
fine dining restaurant experience but he
still
employed a dj to play meg the staff he
said you know he says no caps
no slides no tank to i agree no slides
don't wear those
shoes
to y'all fair about that no no cussing
no
jerseys no sacking pants you know what
he's saying no sweat suits
white people do you know what he's
saying no black people yeah yeah yeah
you're black no that is the realest [ __ ]
ever because that is so true anytime
like with club clubs yeah yes clubs are
like no jerseys
no jewelry zoom in back there this is
the first line that you know is not
not for black men no baseball baseball
caps casual
headwear no durex yeah they put them in
their eggs
let's just say i couldn't go in there
look at me look at me i would never be
able to jumper i have kicks on i
had on a jeweler damn i couldn't go in
that restaurant so you want to have me
in your restaurant
no he don't want you that's insane he
don't want you he's that's his the
polite way of saying can't have black
people
and you're a black owned restaurant
that's so messed up and i support
he's tyrone bigham's but also he also
doesn't go
full throttle in that realm because
he's then employing a dj to play that
music
thank you thank you very much he has his
own hang up still like he can't go full
one way or the other
so he's like you know he's a torn man i
think he's yeah his own i think he's
confused he's a narcissist and he also
says
be respectful anyone who's breaking
these rules be respectful when informing
a guest that they're not following our
dress code when he went take that [ __ ]
somewhere else yeah
get the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ] out of my
room do we have anything and you also
have a short sleeve
turtleneck john i have so many questions
that is
i thought he had it rolled down i think
he thinks he was being polite in that
moment yeah i'll tell you this one
the food's popping all right yeah who
cares
what's in it see what i'm saying that's
what he did that before
all right tonight
what do you want to do
my hair parted call me a cracker dog
wait what's his restaurant called
true food which is also that's a chain
there's another part to it true food
kitchen yeah
i believe not getting any black
celebrities you ain't getting anybody
i'll tell you this i go to dallas i'm
going you're going i'm going i gotta try
it out now
you're gonna twerk one oh yeah i want to
see that [ __ ] minion don't play make
this down and i won't shake my ass dude
that's on you that's how you are
employing the dj you play some diplo and
you don't expect me to take my shirt off
yeah
play some elevator music at a low level
if you don't want people to twerk
oh man you could just too oh dude you
can just tell that's at the roster
yeah that's the owner yo what's that
mean you like wait hold on go to that
chicken [ __ ] let me see what this hey
bring up the menu
oh
how dare you do you see this uh southern
fried nashville hot or asian hennessy
bro he sells fish for thirteen dollars
this is some reasonable prices right
here
yeah right
[Music]
that's [ __ ] in the special dessert
peach cobbler seven dollars come back
and cheese shrimp
he's so stupid
[Applause]
god damn i bet it's bomb oh i bet it's
so good look how certain but that looks
small i don't want the small proportions
that's why it's thirteen dollars i got
smaller dude that's a lobster
so yeah it's like deep fried into it
that's like perfect
like for deep-fried food we're just
doing a show it's
between i forget what's up it's in texas
it's between santa
are you gonna stop by i'm trying to see
how far that is
it's literally i think san marcos is
between austin and dallas
literally austin
oh my god that's what's coming in
twerking hold on now no they ain't
twerking they're they're
okay so if you promote damn
oh she's like works
we would just be like you're right that
makes sense
i think she's doing her own like food
show on the internet she's doing like a
review of it yeah
the chevron grits make you want to snap
your mama
there's a table
but beyond the food we've got phenomenal
drinks here too we've got dreams that
catch on fire
we've got i don't want that yeah when we
show them yeah show me something
restaurant girls who go to dress up have
dinner with their friends yeah sounds
like my place
some of the type of place you should get
away with working
every now and then yeah also don't do it
maybe like on a wild night or something
yeah on a wild night a saturday night
also don't do it let me see it also
don't tarnish my man's restaurant yeah
don't [ __ ] this up for us man okay okay
you get a little
i wonder if she's gonna allow
[Applause]
damn that place is lit i want to go [ __ ]
dude
i wanna swinging pickles
yeah it looks like fried pickles pickles
and fries restaurant dude
he did get trashed for doing this
twerking video but i am honestly
i've never heard of it till he got
trashed and i'm on board see that's
i know they're like fancy waffles oh my
god they're miniature waffles
yeah you can dip it in there small as
hell
he can't even finish a meal at
chick-fil-a [ __ ] you know what
maybe he doesn't want you there malcolm
yeah about that yeah
who's that i don't know does he post up
you got a problem
that was uncalled for check out the
foreheads check out the forehands
we all see it here what the [ __ ]
what else you guys got they're not going
to post mucus up in there yeah man
okay so millie bobby brown uh posted
on her instagram story i think it was
yesterday or maybe two days ago
what happened you know about that keep
going yeah
she's like in a car and she talks about
how she was just out shopping with her
mom
and a fan comes up to her she doesn't
say like how old the fan is but she says
it's a woman who came up to her
saying hi are you such and such she says
yes
and she the fan then proceeds to ask her
can i take a video of you
and she thought that it was gonna be a
photo or video with her but she's like
no
no like you just doing whatever it is
you're doing and i'm just gonna video
you while you're in the store that is
weird and
millie bobby brown goes ahead and says
like no i'm not really comfortable with
that i'm with my mom right now we're
just trying to get some christmas
shopping done
and this woman proceeds to kind of
follow her around the store
recording her and she turns around says
like oh can you please stop
she says i'm a human yeah she says i'm a
human this is disrespectful
what does her mom do during i don't know
she doesn't really say what her mom did
i would have tried so she ended up uh
leaving she gets in the car
does the instagram take talk or some
[ __ ] right
i don't know i think she deleted one of
her social media apps
she's also a 16 year old girl that's the
thing like if i'm the mom
i go like a child the mom didn't say
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying
about it it's on the mom to do it but
also but also
like celebrities have dealt with way
worse than this
like girl you're just getting started
right this is bad
tom cruise had some [ __ ] break into his
house and filming she doesn't have that
perspective being sick are you feeling
this dingling
i mean but that's awesome there are
recorded stories
and situations of her ever since she got
onto stranger things of like
older people dm'ing her [ __ ] because she
was a star as a kid yeah i mean
are you accusing drake right now
play this gin
this is [ __ ] when you make a video
about it i was
um an animal and i said you know yes
and she said can i take a video of you
i said um no
but why would anyone want to be taking a
video of of
of me you know like like it's not like
the both of us like of me
at the end of the day i don't need to
justify it to anyone if i don't want to
be taking a video of i don't i don't
have to be
and um i was paying and she walked past
me
and began to video me again and i said
i'm a human being
like what what more do what more can i
ask from you
the answer i asked her she said so i
can't take a video of a human being
and i said no not when i said no it just
makes me upset
when people try and push the boundary
and i just wish people were more
respectful still trying to navigate this
all
and it's still overwhelming i will take
a picture with you
but when you push the boundary and you
try and fight me on it
there are my rights to say no i'm making
this video to say
you you have to show more respect for
others no matter who they are
what they do show respect human
being to human being it's it's just
matter
i respect that no matter no matter you
say it's cut up though it's weird what
more it's cause it's a story i don't
know if you guys know
you don't need to cry but she's young
right you know like that yeah you don't
need to make a video about it even
yeah it's an incident that you could
have if you were older you go that that
person's gross
and they're shitty but water off the
back like if
if you say no can you put that
[ __ ] in the headlock no well
she's doing she's like
she's gonna go oh really no you can if i
was her i'm like man this is [ __ ]
terrible not go to my bank account like
damn that shit's dope
right that's the thing she's that would
be my dad like damn that [ __ ] was great
she's yeah she's yeah that's true she is
young so that's the one thing
her brain is saying so you know i do a
16 what would you do i'd look at my bank
i'm like
and then at 16 i would jump in my
[ __ ] ferrari from stranger things
three
and [ __ ] drive home i i get where
you're coming from
but i remember myself at 16. yeah and i
would have had it if i'm her
and she probably does okay i would have
an ego
out the ass yeah and i'd be like have
you heard the stories on her
no i know that's yeah she's not even
here really
nightmare she didn't get along with the
other kids why not she's way more famous
she's 11. she's 11. you talk about finn
you're talking about you talking about
the the kid who was the wolf gang the
guy who's going to actually
yeah the other kid went on like it and
stuff he's big yeah yeah he's one kid's
[ __ ]
i forget his name no the black kid's the
worst you come out on it
worst actor of all time in a major movie
what's his name finn wolfhard not that
hard i
was close he's a big deal he's big he's
blown up yeah
so they say on set she's a bit of a diva
since she's coming is she the star big
time you've never seen stranger things
oh okay i thought i gave up you're
seeing stranger things one two or three
hell no i stopped in too you guys gotta
start living you stop start living
i think it's white people [ __ ] oh okay
maybe no
you would like it you love the music do
you like the music music
soundtrack's fantastic what's it like
sciency like
it's retro it's like you like aliens
yeah
that might not be let me ask you this do
you like dope [ __ ] yeah
and you would love stranger things do
you like back to the future and like
retro [ __ ]
no i didn't get it um yeah like i just
don't think it's horrible or chappelle
i bet you dig it because it's like 80. i
don't like alien [ __ ]
for you tonight i don't watch a [ __ ]
it's more it's more
it's more uh 80s than it is aliens it's
not even aliens it's like the
philippines okay ultra
it feels so dope it's so well done yeah
it's nostalgic the original thick boy
hopper's on there
hopper he's a state trooper right yeah
it's great it's like a sheriff or
something
yeah it's a great show sometimes you
forget she's 16 when she's
[ __ ] around with drake you know the
drake thing's weird wait what happened
right
drake's dms bobby brown talked about how
uh she and drake text often and he gives
her advice about boys
and she was like maybe fifteen fourteen
doesn't drink everything what was that
doctor
earlier right now that's fine right like
he's so famous
he's probably like this is how you
should deal with it but i don't have a
history of this drake's [ __ ]
rihanna and all these gorgeous women
she's [ __ ]
asap rocky now yeah we don't know
let's see what they said they got a cool
little room how many did i grab
it's fine do you want some josh i'm good
on that [ __ ]
you don't have a sweet tooth no not at
all i'm more this is so crazy
pour more booze before oh they're just
nice if you want more let me know yeah
i'm down yeah they're saying that
they have like a friend yeah so her
parents know who drake is and [ __ ]
yeah it's like a weird situation i don't
think it's that weird you don't think
it's weird
no is he so famous and as far as i know
the dm's are pretty harmless him being
like hey
navigate this way like he's thinking
about who's more famous
plus she was he was famous when he was
her age yeah that's right so maybe
not to her level his age yeah he was on
like the grass so to me i feel like he's
just navigating like
hey do this dude don't do that be
careful of this
i love you so much though something like
that yeah that's weird you know that's
weird
there's some things you could probably
take out of it and go like this is weird
it's text messages you know like yeah
i'm finding this with twitter as my
audience grows
people will like if you just reply to
somebody people like you don't need to
get defensive
and you're like i'm just replying to
your dog like i'm not getting defensive
yeah it's
literally right exactly yeah i get in
trouble with text too because my text
will be so
harsh but it's like it's text i'm just
talking there's no context there's thank
you so much
i'm yeah i'm just talking and you're
just like you know people like they have
they take wild um what's the word like
uh assumptions
assumptions yeah damn dog that's fine
it's all good yeah it's all good
that's what i used to say too are you so
yeah i didn't know that
chappelle and i hung out one time at ucb
oh yeah that show was
i showed up to that trash show wasted by
the way did you even notice
i was [ __ ] like what's so chapped
i was wasting like showed up to that
show so i just knew it was gonna be
garbage
i hate ucb i'm glad it closed uh
i i [ __ ] noticed i ever laughed
no there was no [ __ ] there was nobody
there it was just the people that showed
up like even the people that showed up
it was just like yeah they worked there
i hate it
so bad i mean i didn't i don't think
that i i don't think anyone i think
there would be laughs
yeah yeah but like it wasn't fun i went
up there not giving if i was like
border i went out with a girl beforehand
i was like black okay okay
and that's what i was going to ask you
but i don't want to say it out loud
that's okay
he's single yeah i'm single why am i huh
oh she's um
[ __ ] i can't say this
so somebody uh sent in a video of the
spider-man that you hired
he is on tick-tock now you heard a guy
you have a spider-man for my son's
birthday and it's the nightmare
and by random guy i mean jack black is
on tick-tock in a spider-man suit
[Music]
but he didn't have the onesie it was two
pieces so his gut was stuck
oh [ __ ] and he kept sweating and lifting
the mask where did you hire him from
time uh hollywood boulevard or
basically yeah my girl hired him for a
hundred dollars oh he kept looking at me
you could tell he's on chicks he kept
doing this with his teeth it was a
nightmare my god that's terrible shut
the [ __ ] up
this was sent in from bella raja on
twitter
that's hilarious man i'm sorry you had
to deal with that
ah it's fun i got a bid out of it yeah
yeah fun
100 bucks i mean who cares right yeah uh
i mean what's your favorite
kid i hate spider-man now but yeah
that's fine that would be traumatizing
yeah
what the [ __ ] spiderman lost it man so a
member of
european parliament a hungarian
politician
was caught in a 25 man sex
orgy and he is super anti-lgbt
damn them boys getting half hungry all
around 25
25 and they caught him as he was like
trying to like jump out the window
yeah because police raided and then and
then the gay boys grabbed him and [ __ ]
i don't know if the gay boys grabbed him
but uh the police definitely did there
were other members
uh like other politicians there as well
but he was the main one that was named
and he's known as a
anti-gay yeah he's literally all
possible but here's the thing about
hungary
all politicians i mean it is illegal to
be gay there
yeah essentially you get killed if
you're gay yeah yeah i mean it's
against the law so therefore it's also
people get murdered
that's why he was trying to run away so
yeah so i mean i don't know if he's like
he's anti-gay because he's a politician
but like
it's like a again to bring it back to
sopranos veto from the sopranos remember
how
the gay dude in the in the mob what
season the plot line
ended last season he was uh there was a
gay dude in the mob
hold on the short white guy yeah vito
vito the the guy he went to like new
hampshire and [ __ ] up firemen for a
while and then came back and then he got
murdered
he died yeah yeah he got murdered that
was gay like three or something seasons
no this season
yeah yeah that dude yeah wait hold on
timeout he was gay
yeah you don't remember that that was a
whole plot line johnny that was his
storyline dude yeah that was his whole
storyline well i didn't pay attention to
him but he was a good guy
he was he's a great actor this guy so
that guy so what they do with this guy
so he was gay yeah he was gay and they
thought they like just
busted him like maybe 25.
yeah he just resigned yeah he's going to
be in trouble he's going to be in a lot
of trouble in hungary yeah
they might they're not going to kill him
oh bubba hopefully they don't
yeah hopefully not but i don't know
you got it you got it it's hungry dude
it's hungry they do not [ __ ] around they
don't
[ __ ] around their parliament meetings
about gay people
sound like you're listening to a [ __ ]
from like the city yeah it's such a
bummer they talk about them like they're
animals yeah it's really
[ __ ] wild so how do i want to know
like how did this gang bang come about
because what do you mean because they
have to suppress themselves so
they have your day they all get together
i think they probably
undergo
if you're a wealthy gig person back in
in that era and you have to suppress it
you have like
prohibition-esque sort of parties about
[ __ ] it's all
underground yeah underground gay world
it's like raves and [ __ ]
and then they get done and they're like
damn dude and it makes it hotter
probably they're like okay
yeah you know how wrong it is to the
outside world so it's like
probably hotter that's the best sex
that's why he's all about it he's like a
politician he's like yin and yang
to the max so it's an adrenaline rush
for him yes oh do them
probably harry hungarians just
just get after it under the radar yeah
what do you think he was doing topper
bottom oh he's
tall i don't know do they can't they mix
it up you should see their phone
photo maybe then it'll help let me see
them there's a photo on the
article do gay guys choose one of the
others
okay there's our top they're more
they're more like
tweets that boys you think he's a topic
but you don't have a baby you don't know
you don't have any comparisons to other
hungry gay people
yeah you're right like he could be a
[ __ ]
fop for the yeah you might you're right
he could be a little like cub
yeah world yeah what else you got all
right you guys are talking about the nfl
are you aware of a guy named young hoku
hell yeah the kid yeah
yeah the kicker his story is crazy now
remember they
let him go for a little bit a little bit
because he messed up on the i guess a
few first
chargers did right he was on the
chargers right we brought him up on the
chargers
he got cut from there then he went to
like another league because he's korean
where did he go for another league uh i
think they show it here canadian
football league maybe sure cfl
oh he's korean uh aaf oh he went to the
america
the short-lived spring league that
occurred
uh that was back in ah [ __ ] 2019
remember it was like
just started it was like uh american
yeah it was like
three weeks long that was just short
terribly cut by the charging patriots
2017 2019
playing the af aaa and then came back
nfl's leading scorer now crazy huh
really
yeah leading scorer i mean 120 a korean
guy it has to do with the fact that he's
on the terrible falcons but uh
yeah they're team and they can't [ __ ]
score in the red zone and they have
julio jones so that's correct but they
have everything
they have basically the super bowl
hopefully you get out the league soon
that's cool they're going to trade him
into san francisco i bet yeah i mean
he's like a
koreans are going to support him like
crazy and this is where he got famous
too
it was a viral kick you did back in the
day we found him boom he's the man dude
i mean
when he was on the charters he got
drafted by charters in preseason he was
kicking long-ass kicks and then he went
in the season
and choked and it was like kickers are
all mental [ __ ] dude like
they're all [ __ ] wild and weird and
they're like goalies and
hockey that's cool man good for him
i'm glad he's back on top yeah me too
how did you guys like uh kickers back in
your day when you're playing
one of my best friends ryan lindell
kicker of the bills is he on the team
when you were there
cause he was there forever he was there
for like 10 years he's one of my good
buddies
that's your boy yeah yeah oh him and his
wife are
so chill like they used to like love my
radio show or whatever and they would
uh when i was playing football you don't
really look at them like actual players
because they really they don't go
through the same [ __ ] we go through what
year
were you there i'm sorry uh i'd be i
graduated 0-6
so that 0-6-0-7 nice i was like
in the probably in the locker room then
oh really yeah dude i was going around
i locked her more than me no i mean i
was just doing media [ __ ] but yeah
i was there that's wild yeah ryan
lindell was definitely on the team then
cool um so this is a couple
combat sports ones this one was very
surprising tyson jones
pay-per-view numbers came in at 1.2
million buys
it's not that surprising i thought at
the price point i thought it'd be higher
than that
wow really you break a million
no oh wow yeah nah to me i thought it'd
be higher do you think so
at that price point i thought that price
point you know 59 right 49 49.99 that's
a good price point compared to
74.99 we're used to paying well i think
uh
the one uh saturday is what 49.99 it's
not 74 dollars
uh you're talking about that that [ __ ]
that should be worth like 75 dollars
it's gonna be a great fight i don't
think something like you know one guy's
a four to one favorite mount
yeah but this guy haven't fought in a
year it don't matter it's boxing
danny garcia is very he's tough yeah but
and then they're they're going to touch
your favorite yeah
who uh earl spence four to one favorite
and he's in five to one 61 in some odds
this guy got into a car accident yeah i
know you want to bet on it
no i know this is going to sweat on it i
bet it's going to be a great fight
you'll find great fight yeah uh would
you better be closer eight four around
eight
like like so we wait to four oh sign me
up for that
eight to four but it's going to be close
rounds what do you think is gonna happen
spence uh spence dominate another might
win ten do you think a knockout
tattoo are finished i don't know what
anything you guys are talking about are
you thinking
uh later in the rounds maybe yeah are
you saying i know friends could get it
done
it's a monster he hasn't been listen he
hasn't fought in a year you know timing
is everything
i don't care okay it's not that good of
a fight
i guarantee you won't break uh million
pay-per-views you won't bet on that
i bet you're gonna do 500. no because
you okay you you're bringing
outside noise in but you well you said
this weekend's it's 49.99 i said it
should be
74 dollars that's how great oh no the
great the fighters are they need money
they need people to watch it
well earl spence has a name continue
okay we'll move on i wish i could weigh
in i don't know
what you're talking about uh one last
one then john mullaney he said he got
investigated by
uh secret service
i read this story this morning yeah it's
uh he made a trump
basically like a caesar joke about trump
or whatever
snl and uh they though it is an
elliptical type premise
they did investigate him about it
i wanted to make a literal assassination
joke about trump
and i toyed with the idea and i did do
it on occasion
and um then i saw shane gillis had an
assassination joke about trump
and his is better so i let him shout out
to the shank
he's great yeah great great um but
nothing happened to him the ca
nothing happened was following him a
secret service they opened a file on him
which who knows what that even means
yeah but also [ __ ] better with your
resource like our taxpayers are paying
for that
we're all paying for it so what does
that even spend your time yeah
they just like they're like let's just
keep an eye on this yeah i wonder
exactly what it meant
he i think he fluffed it up to mean more
than it was remember he had an
interrogation session that he was
bitching about but that's all he really
got from it you know
so weird man
well there you go yeah if you're on
broadcast television you talk about like
what's weird about murdering the
president you know what i mean like
that's so strange all right well man
this crew is uh headed to boise this
saturday there's oh man
yeah there are 15 tickets left you guys
are boise one theater one night only
that is saturday december 5th
then west palm beach palm beach improv
uh december 31st to january 2nd bringing
the
new year's end this [ __ ] shitty 2020
with me and the crew at west palm beach
florida
december 31st through january 2nd
t5k.com for tickets
thickboy.com for your thick boy and
thick girl gary just dropped some
new [ __ ] so go get it josh potter is his
name
that's right josh potter show every
tuesday on the ymh
uh youtube channel thank you so much
dude i appreciate you paying attention
to it yeah
um also uh i'm gonna be in the west palm
improv the
you know when you're talking march march
24th tickets
get them tickets just keep an eye out
they might not be on sale yet but uh
out and um other than that my friend
thank you so much for having me of
course
appreciate you josh thank you we're out